et à peine arrivée au pouvoir nicolas
sarkozy va se retrouver confronté au
problème des parachutes dorés les
affaires se multiplient après noël
forgeard c'est cette fois le directeur
général délégué de ads qui demanderait
une indemnité de départ de 7 à 8
millions d'euros
une affaire d'autant plus choquant que
les allemands affirment que c'est le
gouvernement français qui a imposé la
prime de départ de noël forgeard yvon
martinet à la location thomas enders
coprésidents allemande eads ne mâche pas
ses mots
le gouvernement français nous a tordu le
bras c'est le titre fracassant extraits
de l'interview qui libre ce matin au
quotidien allemand frankfurter zeitung
thomas senders dénonce ainsi la pression
exercée pour que soit versé le golden
parachute de huit millions et demi
d'euros
à noël forgeard directement visé thierry
breton ministre des finances pour un
jour encore ce matin il n'a pas souhaité
nous répondre
lima décidément ou le chez eads
alors qu'un autre dirigeant du groupe
jean-paul but serait en passe de
négocier une prime de départ de 7 à 8
millions d'euros lui aussi pour les
syndicats c'en est trop pour en finir
définitivement il faut légiférer sur le
sujet et empêcher que ces pratiques
puissent perdurer les candidats à la
présidence de la république que nous
avons rencontré s'était engagé là dessus
sarkozy n'a pas été
le moins prolixe sur le sujet bien
maintenant il faut passer des paroles
aux actes
même au medef on s'insurge de cette
nouvelle affaire fumasse je suis fumeur
cette fois c'est l'opacité de ces
pratiques qui fâchent j'ai pas été
regarder dans le dictionnaire exactement
ce que voulait dire fumasse mais c'est
quand même ce que je ressens j'estime
qu'il est de la responsabilité de ads de
communiquer et de s'expliquer le bon
élève du jour c'est lui henri de
castries le patron d'axa alors que son
entreprise va bien déclare ce matin
qu'il renonce aux stock options
auxquelles ils auraient droit cette
année
ils réclament la suppression des
parachutes dorés ce dernier il faut dire
possède déjà 70 millions d'euros en
actions